ladies and gentlemen colleagues and
Friends
the Ukrainian economy has shown
extremely resilience in the face of this
terrible War
the more the economy continues to
operate today
the faster will be the recovery tomorrow
the more Ukraine exports
the more we can tackle a global food
crisis
so it is a global interest
to act now in support of the solidarity
Lanes
allowing vital Ukrainian exports to flow
transport links Logistics storage
should be repaired maintained upgraded
at the European Investment Bank we have
dispersed 1.7 billion euros to Ukraine
since the start of the war
with the idea to support projects that
make economic sense
500 million Euros are devoted to upgrade
the rail and Road Networks
in addition over the next year the Erb
intends to finance up to 300 million
euros for infrastructure projects that
respond to the objectives of the
solidarity Lanes
the idea of the European Commission have
launched the Justice technical advisory
initiative
to better connect the Ukrainian and
moldovan Railway networks to the EU
we are assisting Ukraine Moldova and the
other neighbors to implement quality
cross-border solutions that we're ready
to consider the financing of these
Investments
you can further increase our Collective
impact
by leveraging essential EU guarantees
with Team Europe
we can help Ukraine build the
foundations for a strong
independent European country and tickle
Global hunger
thank you very much for your attention